ya has pasado gran parte de tu vida
matemática hablando de funciones la idea
básica es que dada una entrada válida en
una función es decir un miembro del
dominio de la función la función lo que
nos dirá a partir de la entrada que le
aplicamos serán cuál es la salida
correspondiente y llamamos a la salida
correspondiente como ft x así por
ejemplo hay varias formas de definir
funciones podrías decir algo como que fx
es igual a equis cuadrada esto significa
que cuál sea la x lo que sea que pongas
dentro de la función
la salida será la entrada elevada al
cuadrado
otro ejemplo puedes tener una función
definida de esta manera
f x es igual a x cuadrada si x es impar
y puedes decir que fx es igual a x
kubica en cualquier otro caso y bueno si
tenemos un número impar entonces es un
entero y si tenemos un entero
un par lo que haremos es elevarlo al
cuadrado de lo contrario para cualquier
otro número real lo elevaremos a la
tercera potencia esta es una forma
válida de definir una función ahora lo
que haremos en este vídeo es explorar
una nueva forma de definir una función y
esta es usando una integral definida
pero es la misma idea general lo que
tengo aquí graficado este es el eje t y
este es el eje y tenemos la gráfica de
la función f
o puedes ver esto como la gráfica de que
igual a ft esta es otra forma de
representar que salidas obtendrás para
una entrada dada si te es igual a 1 ft
es igual a 57 es igual a 4 ft es igual a
3 pero ahora definir una nueva función
con base en la integral definida de ft
digamos que nuestra nueva función que
llamaremos gdx
sea igual a la integral definida de
menos 2 a x de ft dt ahora pausa este
vídeo y toma un tiempo para observar la
puede ser que se vea elegante pero lo
que está pasando aquí es que dada una
entrada x que de x se define con base en
la expresión que pudiera tener esta
integral definida para esta x para
entenderlo mejor podemos hacer una tabla
y pensar en algunos valores posibles
aquí tenemos a x y ag de x por aquí y si
x es igual a 1 a que será igual de x ok
pues g de 1 es igual a la integral
definida de menos 2 am y ahora x vale 1
en esta situación este es el valor que
estamos ingresando en la función
entonces uno será nuestro límite
superior de fp
a que es igual esto bueno esto será el
área por debajo de la curva y por encima
del eje entre t igual a menos 2 y t
igual a 1 será esta área de aquí como
tenemos una cuadrícula podemos
encontrarla fácilmente podemos separarla
en dos secciones primero tengo esta
sección rectangular que tiene tres de
base y cinco de altura por lo tanto
tiene un área de 15 unidades cuadradas
mientras que la sección triangular de
arriba tiene una base de 2 y una altura
de 1 por lo tanto su área serán 2 por 1
por un medio lo cual será 1 por lo tanto
esta área que buscamos es de 16 que pasa
ahora si x es igual a 2 cuánto será g de
2 pausa el vídeo e inténtalo bueno g de
2 es igual a la integral definida de
menos 2 am y ahora nuestro límite
superior tomará la entrada que estamos
ingresando en la función es decir 2
de ft dt entonces esta vez tenemos el
área que va desde aquí hasta acá y esta
área es igual al área que ya calculamos
que sabemos que son 16 unidades
cuadradas más otras 123 45 unidades
cuadradas
por lo tanto 16 más 5 es igual a 21
espero que todo esto te ayude la clave
aquí es que podemos definir funciones
válidas usando integrales definidas pero
esto será todo en este vídeo nos vemos
en el siguiente